- But right now, I think
we have a woman here
that we are obsessed with on the line.
You can tell we're obsessed with her
because she's been here like 40,000 times
'cause we love her and
she's funny and that's why.
So, everybody, say hi to Whitney Cummings.
(audience cheers)
(upbeat music)
- Thank you, Kelly.
- Hello!
(audience claps)
Where are you?
- Well, I'm in my podcast
studio at my house
which is like a weird Pee-wee's Playhouse
of everything that fans send me.
I'm a hoarder.
(Kelly laughs)
So, I have everything that's
ever mattered to me in life
in here that's inspired me.
I've got my CK1.
- Oh my gosh.
(Kelly laughs)
That's amazing.
- There's a delay so I'm
not sure if I'm bombing
or if you can hear me.
(Kelly laughs)
I've got from the movie, 'The Labryinth'.
(audience cheers)
This is the worm from 'The Labyrinth'.
- I love The Labyrinth!
Yes, when he goes, oooh!
And the rocks come, yes!
- My god!
Kelly, I named my new puppy Ludo.
(audience cheers)
- Oh my gosh.
So cute.
- His name is Ludo!
- Oh, I love The Labryinth is literally
one of my favorite films of all time.
Wait, you're in a movie!
Okay.
With Dave Grohl, this is awesome.
How did this happen?
(audience cheers)
- So, The Foo Fighters made a horror movie
and it's Dave Grohl and his band.
They go to record their 10th album.
They're struggling to get inspired.
So they decide to go to
some creepy house in Encino
and just all do it together
and it has really good sound.
And then slowly, Dave Grohl
starts being possessed
by a demon and killing his entire band.
(Kelly laughs)
And I play the very looks way
younger than she is neighbor
(Kelly laughs)
who was a groupie in the nineties
and kind of slept through
every rock band in Hollywood
and now,
- Awesome.
lives next door to this
house to try to sort of,
you know, get a job as a
backup singer with any band
that comes through.
So in the, the only reason I
said yes to doing the movie
is because there is a scene.
Well, the only reason I
didn't say no, how about that?
I'm dying to do it but there's a scene
where I have to sing a
song to the entire band
to audition, like, do
you need a backup singer?
And in the script it was a
heart song called Magic Man.
- Oh yeah.
Love Magic Man.
- That's a hard song to sing
even for singers, right?
Please say yes.
- Well, Anne Wilson is one
of the greatest singers
of all time.
So, yeah.
Yeah.
- I'm having to sing that but
it doesn't have to be good.
Okay?
But I'm like, okay.
I'm horrible at singing in a
way that it's not even funny.
It's more sad.
(Kelly laughs)
So I'm singing and poorly.
And I do it and they're like,
okay, we're gonna take a break.
They come back and they go,
hey, we've brought on a
vocal coach to work with you.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- Just to make it.
(Kelly laughs)
I'm like but isn't it supposed to be bad?
And they're like, not that,
that's just different.
- Oh my god.
Wait, wait.
I think we have tape.
I think we have a clip.
Wait, let's see this clip real quick.
Yep, yep.
- Oh, no.
- I'm Samantha.
I live right next door.
I just wanted to introduce myself
in case you boys needed anything.
A cup of sugar, back up singer.
♪ I got another confession to make ♪
♪ I'm no fool, ah ♪
♪ Were you born to resist or be abused? ♪
(Kelly laughs)
- I just need you to know.
- Don't be jealous.
- That you are my favorite
kind of karaoke bar singer.
Like when you go to karaoke,
you're my favorite one.
Just so you know, that's real.
- 'Cause I'm the one that
doesn't let anyone on the stage.
Once I'm on
- Exactly, exactly.
- It's duets with me only.
(Kelly laughs)
- Or my backup dancer.
(Whitney laughs)
- Exactly.
You could hold the microphone
for me, if you want.
Kelly, can you get me a water?
- I'm just feeling a little
So, notice that was not the heart song.
I get there and I'm like, okay.
I've emotionally prepared
myself to sing this heart song
in front of some of the best
musicians that ever lived.
- Yeah.
- I can do this,
I can do this.
I had a little Jacobs Creek,
(Kelly laughs)
had a little wine at 11:00 AM.
I'm feeling confident.
(Kelly laughs)
And then they go, hey,
we are having trouble
licensing the heart song.
We're just gonna have you sing
Everlong by The Foo Fighters.
(Kelly laughs)
(Kelly claps)
- Like it's a quick fix,
like a quick change.
- Well, no, so now I have
to sing their song to them
and make eye contact with
them the entire time.
(Kelly laughs)
By the way, Dave, I love you.
I love The Foo Fighters.
I don't know that song acapella!
(Kelly laughs)
(Kelly claps)
- Now I have to go memorize it.
I dry humped to that song a
long time ago and I don't,
I haven't listened to it recently.
I know, this one isn't even airing.
(Kelly laughs)
So then, I have a sex scene in the movie
and everyone's running around
like, are you gonna be okay?
Like, do you need this
bra, this underwear?
I'm like, I don't care
about the sex scene.
Everybody can see me naked
but the singing the song.
We have to, I need time.
(Kelly laughs)
- That's that's your line.
- Have you ever had someone
sing one of your songs to you
like four inches away
from your face horribly?
I mean, that's what I
had to do to Dave Grohl.
- Yes.
In a bar.
- So embarrassing.
(Whitney laughs)
- That's happened to me in a
bar and they were intoxicated.
And it was awesome.
It was funny.
It wasn't great.
But God said make a joyful
noise, not a perfect one.
(audience laughs)
You know?
Okay, so, the movie is
called Studio 666, right?
- Yes, it's called Studio 666.
It is, at a time where so
many movies and entertainers,
not that there's anything wrong with it,
are bringing politics into their work
or things have gotten so apocalyptic
and sometimes you watch TV
and you just wanna have
a glass of whiskey.
Everything's kind of so depressing.
This movie is just fun
to throw back to those
campy, horror movies we all grew up on.
There's a silliness to it.
- Yep.
- You know, it's a nice
way to just take a break
and not have to think about politics
- Horrible things.
- or how the world is catching on fire.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience claps)
- Well that's awesome.
I cannot wait to see it.
It's so good to see you Whitney.
Thank you so much.
- Sorry about my singing!
(Kelly laughs)
Say bye!
- Bye!
Oh my gosh, so cute.
Everybody, go online for tickets
to Whitney's Touch Me Tour
and be sure to check out Studio 666.
It's only in theaters starting tomorrow.